-Performing
"Problem / Can't Feel My Face,"
please welcome Lorna Courtney,
Ben Jackson Walker,
and the cast of "& Juliet."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Baby, even though I hate ya,
I wanna love ya ♪
-♪ Ooh-ooh-ooh-ooh-ooh ♪
-♪ And even though I can't
forgive you, I really want to ♪
-♪ Ooh-ooh-ooh-ooh-ooh ♪
-♪ Tell me, tell me, baby,
why can't you leave me? ♪
♪ 'Cause even though I shouldn't
want it, I gotta have it ♪
-♪ Ooh-ooh-ooh-ooh-ooh ♪
♪ Head in the clouds,
got no weight on my shoulder ♪
♪ I should be wiser and realize
that I've got ♪
♪ One less problem without ya ♪
♪ I got one less problem
without ya ♪
♪ One less problem without ya ♪
♪ I got one less problem
without ya ♪
♪ One less problem without ya ♪
♪ I got one less,
one less problem ♪
♪ I know you're never gonna
wake up, I gotta give up ♪
-♪ But it's you-ooh-ooh ♪
-♪ I know I shouldn't ever call
back or let you come back ♪
-♪ But it's you-ooh-ooh ♪
-♪ Every time you touch me
and say you love me ♪
♪ I get a little bit
breathless ♪
♪ I shouldn't want it ♪
-♪ But it's you-ooh-ooh ♪
-♪ Head in the clouds,
got no weight on my shoulder ♪
♪ I should be wiser and realize
that I've got ♪
-♪ One less problem without ya ♪
♪ I got one less problem
without ya ♪
♪ I got one less,
one less problem ♪
♪ One less problem without ya ♪
♪ I got one less problem
without ya ♪
♪ I got one less,
one less problem ♪
-♪ And I know she'll be
the death of me ♪
♪ At least we'll both be known ♪
♪ And she'll always get
the best of me ♪
♪ The worst is yet to come ♪
♪ But at least we'll both
be beautiful ♪
♪ And stay forever young ♪
♪ Yes, I know ♪
-♪ Yes, I know ♪
-♪ Yeah, I know ♪
-♪ She told me
don't worry about it ♪
♪ She told me
don't worry no more ♪
♪ We both know we can't go
without it ♪
-♪ Head in the clouds,
got no weight on my shoulder ♪
♪ I should be wiser and realize
that I've got ♪
♪ One less problem without ya ♪
♪ I got one less problem
without ya ♪
♪ I got one less,
one less problem ♪
♪ I got one less problem
without ya ♪
♪ I got one less,
one less problem ♪
-♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh-oh-oh ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh-oh-oh ♪
-♪ One less problem ♪
♪ One less ♪
♪ Problem, problem, problem ♪
-♪ Problem ♪
-♪ One less ♪
-♪ I got one less ♪
♪ One less problem without ya ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ohhh! Come on now!
Come on! That's awesome!
The cast of "& Juliet"!
Go see it on Broadway.
Check out the original Broadway
cast recording,
which is streaming now.
For tickets go to
andjulietbroadway.com.